vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf dont il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités da titcha ph
quentin avec moi
dom plante le podcast de cette semaine
et présenté par vegan mais pas plate
écoutez c'est un podcast avec
jean-philippe sourire qui est un chiffre
égal au québec chez vegan très connu au
québec puis puis on a aussi un livre de
cuisine de recettes vegan donc c'est
après la convention que jean-philippe 72
dpi un petit peu dans le véganisme vega
n'est pas plate points comme on a pleins
d'articles à dessus on a plein de
recettes puis chez que demande est un
fervent amateur donc cette semaine
comme j'ai déjà eu ce pôle et on pêche
ben cette semaine comme ph les i c'est
jean-philippe serait en fait pas content
de l'avoir pour la deuxième fois au
podcast c'est un pack as quand même
assez différent du premier à parler
peine de nouveaux sujets avec lui puis
on a parlé d'autre chose que du
véganisme dont premièrement nous parler
de consommation d'alcool slash prennent
de santé mentale
jean philippe jan nouveau podcast
maintenant qui s'appelle comment ça va
comment ça va puis qu'il quittait de ces
sujets le qui fait qu'on a parlé de tout
ce après ça on ne peut pas parler un
petit peu de ne parler beaucoup de
méditation mass moca cela beaucoup
beaucoup
jean-philippe fans de retraite vipassana
des dix jours des méditations fait qu'on
a parlé de tous de l'ebit les bienfaits
de la méditation comment commence à ce
moment ça marche dans des retraites
comme ceux on a parlé bien sûr de vega
nice vient pas en lien avec la coved 19
ans formant qu'est ce qui se passe dans
l'industrie de la viande des animaux de
ceux qui on a parlé serait pas mal de
tours au fait que c'est une super belle
conversation avec jean philippe qui
quitte un communiqué communicateur hors
pair super drôle smartphone pas que
toujours un plaisir
puis ça me faisait craquer à méditer les
2,6 ainsi comme nous après la après la
discussion vous avez envie de méditer je
vous encourage à le faire de moi je sais
quelque chose que je veux commencer le
cigare est ce que c'est quelque chose ça
fait longtemps que j'ai dans mon bras
d'or ça serait bon facile tant pis t&t
on le sait quelle mouche peu trop
ésotérique le ton monte mais c'est que
des fois c'est comme la médiation ce
qu'on m'associe
un peu à certains coureurs mais il ya
vraiment quelque chose de si je pense
que tout le monde a intérêt à méditer
pic c'est vraiment comme jean-philippe
en parle maintenant pas au terrain
justement c'est vraiment axé sur la
connaissance de touapsé émotion s'est
fixé que vous allez voir la conversation
est vraiment intéressant pour nous et on
met dans une bonne journée zone come on
come on les chéris pas mal podcast de
cancer quand ce genre de choses là
arrivent donc sinon écouter le cd
commentaires abonnez-vous à notre
patronne est le document va faire péter
une petite semaine survient juste
exclusif à nos membres donc aller nous
aller le lien va être dans le fait dans
des fonctions du podcast laisser des
commentaires laissés beijing et hop hop
ça fait son bout de chemin
puis surtout surtout écouter le podcast
fait que bonne écoute
[Musique]
arrête jean-philippe merci d'être là
merci de l'invitation
hier ça a été derrière mes notes merci
pour ta flexibilité et quand j'ai pas
grand chose à faire est ainsi prête à
tout pour manu aujourd'hui c'est que tu
fais tes journées d'ailleurs quand même
chose que d'habitude je me paye ma
carrière non mais moi j'étais un
influent pense pas qu'on fait pas
grand-chose lit des livres je vends des
recettes je mange je fais des vidéos
mais je me souhaite quand même concédé
pas mal de guigues je fais du spectacle
qu'on fait ici au dos et mon impression
d manger mon stand up de démonstrations
culinaires qui est pas vraiment une
démonstration culinaire une conférence
pour c'est ça la plate quand on dissout
une conférence aux pressions qu'ils
nomment j'essaie de faire un petit peu
d'ambiance a tout foutu fait un peu en
fait si tu fais quasiment 3 avoir tu
fais quasiment une conférence une démo
puis un stand up comique en même temps
bon tout le temps mais ma foi
aujourd'hui les gens qui viennent voir
mémo mamo trois fois de suite jusqu'aux
des médecins qui récupère des jo le
magicien argentin de san mames adonis a
peut-être été repérées dont un magicien
un match amateur change de trucs un
magicien professionnel change de public
d'emprunt le job de tofu je peux pas
inventer tous les jours j'ai pas le
choix dans les cycles 1 mm du nombre de
blagues te fuite qui est possible
d'exister rhinois mais pas que la bouffe
c'est pas ça pousse pas tarder à garder
la crème de la crème des blogs de jeu
migros sinon mes journées garde
je crée des recettes je travaille la
maison moi ça fait que ça change pas
grand chose dans ma ville je me rends
compte que je voyageais pas mal ouais
on allait souvent
inspiré il reste aussi c'est ça bah oui
mais les restos moi je m'inspire
beaucoup d'un restaurant joies d'un
resto puis je goûte à ce jeu là c'est
une bonne idée on allait souvent à new
york mais savait pas tort non plus de
rester chez nous un peu oui
puis elle part pendant le confinement de
te lancer un nouveau podcast
oui comment ça va ouais ouais ce que tu
parles de santé mentale ouais c'est un
put project 26e at-il s'imputent project
en français un projet d'éducation un
projet de câble ce soit je trouvais que
ça valait la peine dans ces temps ci je
sais que c'est pas facile pour tout le
monde avec le confinement puis tout ce
qui arrive là de rester sain mentalement
je dois parler des jeunes qui sont plus
ou moins connus le souvent c'est des
artistes qui ont vécu des problèmes de
santé mentale ou pas nécessairement des
gens qui va juste nous parler de
l'équipe l'anxiété moi j'veux pas pour
le prêche pas pour acquis que y'a
toujours là mais quelqu'un qui en a pas
de problèmes de santé mentale jamais
dans notre société on ne te on a tout
des faiblesses n'oserait qu'un temps
confinement comme ça ça vient exacerber
bain des affaires surtout pour nous
autres je suis grillé par jeff stein
effluents à sam c'est vrai on se nourrit
un peu du monde
on rencontre des gens on a une vie
publique vie se retrouver l'élite sauf
moi de soda c'est l'étudiant nike son
compte elle
mais quand je vois le monsieur mocky qui
nettoyait la rue à tout les jours en
avance chez nous parce que déjà pour
appeler rulon centaine je me dis unique
sont en train de virer fou comprit vite
et pour prendre que le monsieur qui qui
qui n'est total rue où le monsieur qui
nettoie sa rue devant chez nous mettons
nous tous ce monsieur là où qu'il a 14
fois son patio par jour pour le maxi
jean lot 6 t d il y avait des habitudes
qui était justement social qui ne
serait-ce que d'aller au centre d'achat
ne serait-ce que d'aller voir leurs amis
me choque mon grand père
il sort pas beaucoup de chez eux mais
une des fois qu'ils sortaient de chez
eux c'était pour aller avec toutes ses
amies qui est encore vivant ses amis du
secondaire puis d'aller au buffet des
continents une fois par semaine c'est ce
site est une énorme activité dans sa
semaine mais leur soeur tu l'enlèves
complètement pour une durée indéterminée
qui pour ces gens là probablement que la
durée va être encore plus longue qui est
pour nous l'un - effectivement bon pas
les retraités et puis c'est petit parti
poule avec ses amis de madame mais en
appui comme tu dis souvent ces gens ces
gens je sais c'est comme le clou de la
semaine tu as besoin de te pour sortir
un petit peu de la maison des fois pour
les couples aussi c'est moins facile
c'était soir avec quelqu'un mais tout
d'un coup tu es dans la même pièce
pendant 24h sur 24 pendant quelques
semaines fait que j'ai pas de ce1 dans
l'optique de essayer d'aider les gens
qui souffrent un peu
comme j'ai interviewé marcel voyons
problèmes de drogue
si c'est vraiment c'est lui qui disait
que c'était pas facile non plus pour les
gens qui ont des problèmes de
consommation de ses ennemis de la
consommation cécile isolement le
dynamisme la nuit des problèmes de
drogue celle isolement ce contexte rien
faire qu'est ce que tu fais pour
dépendantes à chercher une pièce de bien
tu fais 20 juin puis on pas vous allez
regarder bien loin pour voir que les
problèmes d'alcool puis de drogue ces
présents dans notre société quand je
vois les gens faire le line up on avale
escudé c'est en avant la société des
alcools du line-up incroyable je me dis
c'est un service essentiel qui se bat
pour certaines personnes c'est fait que
dans notre société je me dis on va
peut-être y ait des gens qui sont faites
aux pieds des gens qui t'aiment moi je
prends plus d'être comme j'en prends pas
de l'alcool j'en ai déjà puis moi j'ai
déjà été pas l'accrocher à l'alcool
peut-être mais dans ma famille mon grand
père est mort d'alcoolisme il y avait je
pense qu'avec 45 ans fait que j'ai un
bagage familial qui lui beaucoup donc
qui ça suit beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
génétique c'est quand tu es jeune tu
prends ta première brosse d'après moi si
tu souhaites portait peut-être avoir des
problèmes à ce niveau le situe près 1
4me quand j'avais 14 15 ans j'ai pris ma
première bière picholine je te
bannissement trop bien les personnalités
thiessois des personnalités excessives
ou des personnalités justement qui qui
sentent mieux le type de peau patchs et
autres choses la même enquête peuple
c'est comme le cette substance lui un
excellent alcoyano xi toute substance et
comme sa vie complice thomas klepis le
sadi problématique
bon bien on vit dans une société
d'extraverti quand tu es jeune d'état de
l'essaim tout le monde est pogné on
pense tout connu des seuls à être pogné
quand on est jeune mais tout le monde
est jeune et homo des teams et tout le
monde est une espèce de carapace pilote
prend de l'alcool souvent ça commence
souvent comme ça les histoires des gens
que j'interviewe dans mon podcast
au début j'ai commencé à prendre le cas
pour me dégêner
puis faire partie de la gang
c'est devenu une habitude puis c'est
devenu un métier ça commence souvent
manière insidieuse comme ça puis c'est
quoi avoir un problème d'alcool ils
disent que si je prends de l'alcool sais
pas combien de temps après le temps que
je vais prendre deux bières à soi puis
travail lent mais ma tête en a pris 14
un problème d'alcool si t'es pas capable
d'arrêter de prendre dans le col
d'izoard la fin de semaine j'en
prendrais pas pu t'en as hb bat un
problème d'alcool c'était pas besoin
d'être là charles pour voir l'une
d'elles que puis obligé de renoncer non
plus en thérapie pour avoir un problème
d'alcool ton problème d'alcool ça peut
être aussi de potes productif mais je ne
suis la productivité que tu gagnes juste
en plus vendu cette note a plein de
prendre douze bières le soir le
lendemain était bien plus est bien plus
actif des biens plus proactif vous êtes
entraînés tout acheter des podcasts
soifer souhaite proactif je vais juste
utiliser un exemple qui m'est arrivé
dernièrement tellement derrière mans
hier moi ça faisait juste parce que
j'étais en confinement pickeu puis que
je vivais une séparation en même temps
fait que j'ai fait attention pour pas
prendre d'alcool pur porc tomber déprimé
pour rien les soirs et puis ça m'en
rendre compte je me suis rendu à deux
mois sans prendre une dose d'alcool
juste parce que je t'ai chez nous puis
que je faisais rien mais je courais mes
performances physiques était débile
mental comme rien comme j'ai vécu avant
qui samedi
je suis allé dans un parc avec une gang
d'amis qui ont gibus les jibuls
habilleur puis quand je suis revenue
chez nous je me sentais fort puis hier
toute la journée je t'es une merde
généralement une merde j'ai essayé
d'aller courir parce que j'avais
planifié étude allait courir parce que
je suis d'avoir un os reste t'il quand
même strict
j'étais allé courir je m'alignais pour
un 20 km puis après 6,7
mais une prestation était dans le tapis
j'avais envie de vomir
puis ma journée on était de la merde
littéralement de la mer juste à cause de
tube je veux dire j'ai pas jeu martin
ger pas blake et alger pas être sans
surprise 60 ans de votre corps non c'est
ça qui est c'est vraiment si j'ai jamais
de toute ma vie j'ai jamais aussi
remarqué clairement l'effet néfaste
de l'alcool sur mon corps que hier j'ai
joué aussi clair que ce nom c'est un
poison c'est pas parce que tu m'aies jus
de fruits d'atebank de l'éthanol comme
que pour toutes ces raisons là je trouve
effectivement insiste vraiment une
espèce de romantisme nation aussi de
l'alcool sur les réseaux sociaux de plus
des bus confinement c'est tout le monde
mérite une barre de 28 ans tu as one à
pleines mains une pipe plein d'affaires
demande de pardon expert va de 20 comme
tu disais pph tu fais pas d'autres
choses restent comme cet avis et manu tu
te réveilles au mode zombie
si j'ai fait les dix dernières années ça
fait peut-être dix ans que j'ai arrêté
de boire d'alcool point qu'il irait pour
ça
mais s'impose sans si je vais peut-être
un verre de vin il a souvent quand je
vais au restaurant pour accompagner ma
blonde mais je vous envoie deux gorgées
je sais juste pourquoi faudrait il était
de 105
c'est surtout c'est la pression sociale
ou non pas quelqu'un d'autre un problème
d'alcool têtu et têtu
est-ce quelque chose qui vaut pour
coincer fait que tant qu'à se prennent
bien ce quinté peut citer c'est
d'arrêter de consommer puis td1 que les
canadiens vont pas te promener avec une
bière dans un parti mais si tu veux
éviter l'astra situation sociale et rien
qui est mieux prendre un verre de vin
visaient pas le boire de l'alcool
tout le monde pense que tu poses
naumenko c'est quelque chose qui est
réel la pression sociale de bois
d'alcool c'est tellement c'est tellement
omniprésente c'est moi une fois dans ma
vie j'étais là je parle un break que
j'ai arrêté pendant trop mauvais c'est
juste pour dire que je trouvais le
chômage que je consommais plus petit
jamais pour vos problématiques mais je
me suis bon pour faire le tour juste
prendre un petit break pendant trois
mois
c'est d'ailleurs que je jouais beaucoup
musique d'abord je m'en foutais de temps
n'est pas actée
la justification juste premièrement
comme un gamin
awkward fait sentir dans un boîtier mais
magazine constat avec quelqu'un que j'ai
pas un vab dans ma main puis justement
la question si ça peut être 5 10 fois
par part soit on le dit qu'il fallait
que j'explique les raisons pour
lesquelles ces bois pendant la nuit
enfin c'est rendu que celle des coq avec
les sucs faisaient du déjà de jager
juste pour dire que je me tendant gagne
mais c'est parce que parce que justement
tréziers yes l'alcool agit comme un
genre de lubrifiant social c'est pour
justement déjeuné le monde qui stimule
et les conversations les rapprochements
au city fait classer comme bon bon mais
quand à bois pourrait peut-être que tu
es comme avant les gens il y avait si
guéret a remarqué qu'entre les gens
rentraient dans un parti tout le monde
salue même s'ils restent c'est comme les
gens sont stressés les ministères et des
stars ça a été le cellulaire maintenant
cela en place s il ya les gens risquent
d'emporter sont se sent mal à l'aise au
ils vont regarder la télé ils vont
suffoquer leur cellulaire puis comme se
dit surtout 3d dans le domaine du
spectacle fait des prestations d'un bar
souvent ça des jeunes steven gin tonic
moi aussi j'ai fait des juifs et de
chansonniers du gange était plus jeune
non violente fait payer des verres puis
c'est pas le meilleur show non plus un
moment donné le meilleur show mais des
fois ce mois-ci sautiller comme l'espèce
des lignes avec lesquels jouer parce que
le fait de boire justement ça en train
de fois les le public à être plus le
parti pis tu ta job c'est d'être l'eau
pour n'être le monde ce parti peut il
réussir leur entrée dans une petite
grenouille agents à deux heures et demie
du soir quand c'est le chansonnier et
arraché puis tout le monde et genre tout
le monde a progressé en même temps dans
soirée le toi tu arrives dans ce que tu
vois le comportement du fait qu un n'ya
rien qu'ils fournissent pour l alcool ça
peut faire faire des affaires tellement
le
ridicule au monde c'est moi j'ai
justement des fois il déçoit que je me
disais je boirai pas soit parce que je
peux pas boire quatre qui des fois je te
mal à d'autres auteurs du matin quand
tout le monde est bien chaude voix des
enfants tu dis et boyle à la bêtise
humaine
l'alcool peut vraiment faire ressortir
ce td fois ci c'est pas chic laisser
s'en rend pas plus intelligent on a
l'impression que ça rend plus créatif ça
rend plus créatif ça brime la créativité
si tu prends un couple rendement des
seuils des jeux des blagues de céder que
c'est d'être créatif ça marche pas
hemingway hemingway de six cordes
fameuse c'est lui lutté beaucoup avec le
avec l'alcoolisme le plein de ses
courtes fameuse serait- drogue et
d'êtres sur beurre fait car des sous
pour goûter sous l'effet de n'importe
quel nom importe quelle substance tu
peux écrire tes idées mais c'est jamais
bon s'il faut que quelqu'un tue les ai
dit tu les rliss faut que soit joint
complètement sur le coup c'est bon
trouve ça extraordinaire
le trio ouais tu parles de
l'aromatisation de l'alcool sur les
réseaux sociaux en ce moment en tant que
figure présente sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que ios que plus que jamais les
gens sont là dessus les gens suivent
tout ce que tu fais comment est-ce que
comment est ce que tu trouves ça cette
période ici en tant que créateurs de
contenu digital mais moi j'ai toujours
se trouver sur je trouvais ça difficile
les réseaux sociaux parce que c'est une
arme à double tranchant
on en a besoin pour l'alimenter pis et
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça
qu'elle accusait jean philippe rey c'est
comme ça que mon projet est né - c'est
sur facebook je faisais des vidéos puis
au début je me montrerai pas je montrais
les recettes mais je me renvoyaient pôle
emploi est juste mais même moment donné
je me suis mis plus en avant
je sais c'est de là que j'ai eu des
contrats d'édition que tout ce qui
s'ensuit
mais c'est pas évident de se mettre sur
la place publique parce qu'on porte
flins ou qui risquent d'éclipser cannes
ouais ouais puis tout le monde est
parfait tout le monde est parfait sur
les réseaux sociaux stadiers ci dessus
des fois tu proposes tu penses posée la
semaine passée je vois je porte un
masque
tu vas donner l'exemple
ce que je suis pour le port du masque ça
fait que j'ai dit je dois porter un
masque mais là je l'enlève pour parler
mais je l'enlève pas de la bonne manière
en vrai je me mets le doigt dans mon
masque mais de toute la journée c'est
moi je suis beaucoup ce qui se passe
sûrement content parce que je ne sors
répondent aux gens aussi en a gardé
quelques occasions à tout le monde
ben oui parce que s'ils se répondent
plus par le fil bleu en avoir trop ce
que je me souhaite up to date mais toute
la journée j'ai peut-être 300 personnes
qui m'ont dit tu as le temps mais c'est
une mauvaise manière à stimuler mais
d'après ce lâcher ni d'en masquer c'est
une fois au début je répondais oui merci
je sais c'est cdafal excuse moi juste
pour pouvoir rebondir le coût de la tuer
ce que les gens quittent écrivait
j'imagine qu'à 20 pourcentage qui s'est
juste juste si tu le savais pas mais
c'est sûr qu'ils en avaient aussi qu'il
y avait un ton paternaliste danseurs le
roi jean ça sert à quoi de se mettre un
masque
c'était pour vais me permettre les
doigts de bain ce qui est toujours des
gens puis j'avais pris un demi produits
de cuisine de jean philippe que j'avais
acheté ce fait que je monte je me suis
montré en train de prendre le produit
puis je l'achète je vais manger ce pour
vous un an plus tôt pris un produit dans
tes mains sur leur milo
si je n'ai pas je n'ai pas dormi là je
les achetais pas je vais manger mais
c'est toujours des fois tu doute de rien
je fais ça tu fais un post et compte un
petit diable rouge a partagé une
expérience et contenus du contenu utile
puisque ces péages et est souvent là
dessus puis sur 100 en toute bonne foi
puis tout d'un coup le taux allemand
sera beau ce soit parce que at aurait dû
face moi j'avais vécu je te dirais que
maintenant quand je suis en voyage en
fait plus de story radio tout le temps
quelqu'un qui vont écrire tu voyages tv
gagnent mais tu prends la vie en plus tu
es vegan puis tu prends l'avion
dans ma tête c'est pourquoi ce qu'était
vegan quand tu prends pas l'avion mais
pour certaines personnes c'est souvent
agressif c'est souvent faites ce que je
dis faites pas ce que je fais tu prends
l'avion tu dis moi mais j'ai jamais trop
jeune pour prendre l'avion
je sais tout de limiter mais on peut pas
être parfait
c'est comme quand les gens signé le
pacte lé sentiment d'avoir signé le
pacte parce qu'il y avait deux voitures
se peut pas être parfait
est parfaite le gie du banc pour faire
qu'un autre story la semaine suivant le
dernier os
je veux montrer aux gens comment porte
un masque parce que mon ma femme mes
médecins j'ai laissé vous est maudit
mais ce que côté de niaiser mettez vous
un aspect clé tu devrais montrer comment
est-ce qu'on porte un masque m'inscrire
manière de même se rendre compte qu'il y
avait une manière de ce que fait que je
montre mes story puis dit se démasque
sommes ceux je vais trouver ça sur
amazon la gaffe le maudire amazon fait
le ch'ti participer cependant je finis
ma story bling bling bling bling 3,4
commentaire 5 commentaires en ligne en
temps de paix trois minutes ou des
commentaires négatifs mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut être vegan puis
magazines et sur amazon
[Musique]
c'était juste c'est négatif est que par
mon groupe et moi je montre aux jeunes
comme à matam à ses frais des jo
contenus diffusés des gens qui se
montrait ton masque je fais ma part pour
notre société
j'ai fait ne montre et je fais utilisé
parce qu'elle ait eu beaucoup de gens
qui te qui nous qui nous écrivent en
privé avec ton following qui devrait
faso je peux aussi tout c'est terrible
ça le ph
mais l'époque est quelque chose de
social tue devrait en parler parce que
tintin du monde qui twitte jeu c'est
vrai aussi une responsabilité sociale
des jeunes se fait qu'on a un micro
c'est pourquoi pas l'utiliser à bon
escient
je peux parler de tout non c'est parce
que ces moutons dans les personnes qui
font leur port pour le véganisme au
québec était la personne qui fait le
plus apport pour le véganisme au québec
et probablement le québécois
individuelles qui a sauvé un directement
le plus d'animaux l'ofj auprès dû au
sommet ben moi je dis honte on pense
vaughn sur moi y'a tout il y en a
quelques autres ceux qui n'ont pas de
temps que nos manques en anglais ouais
mais non mais le pointeur et fait encore
beaucoup pour ce mouvement le déjà puis
tu peux pas commencer à porter toutes
les chapeaux ce nom sinon tu passerais
tu ton temps à faire de la justice
sociale sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai vraiment la retraite de fribourg
mais c'est jamais corps et non je sais
qu'on peut pas d'être de tous les
combats menés c'est juste impossible t
il y avait il ya un livre qui traîne et
qui traînait à vue le textile systems
comment être un adulte laurent gerra
quatre cents 400 quelques étapes puis
une des premières étapes c'est définir
qu'est ce qui dans ton cercle d'action
python cercle de deux consonnes sujet
par les fans en m'offrant set mais dans
le fond était de choisir quelque chose
qui préoccupe mais ne faut pas
nécessairement prendre action pour sept
jours parce que tu peux pas juste
prendre action de 2 to l'islande toutes
les injustices les problèmes dans
l'univers affectés et moi mon champ
d'action du lit les choses sur
lesquelles je m'implique y programmant
âgées
c'est sur so so so so i thought i
un nombre limité parce que sinon juste
et vérifie les autres choses ça me
préoccupe oui mais je me dirais passé
peut pas décemment à moi de faire
quelque chose pour sauver mais peut-être
le faire définir ce que c'est à dire
jean philippe ça me faisait passer de
l'autre j'écoutais une entrevue d'un
philosophe français s'appelle andré
comte sponville tpiy lui disait à ce
moment par un d'assistés qui avait déjà
le politically correct et puis l'homme
est intelligent il faudra y ait des
polices des politiques des messages de
maquens eu quatre balles d'amazonie ou
quoi que ce soit puis le tout maintenant
là le la police du sanitairement correct
le tin oo lui pas du matin on lui a mis
son masque pas que pas que lui a faite
si c'est comme le dit ajoutant une au
niveau de destockage speed est chez cage
d d d d immobiliser les gens toujours
que mobiliser les jambes ses jambes qui
culpabilise les autres sur les réseaux
sociaux souvent savoir leur profit d'une
photo de jeu il manque même pas leur
vrai visage souvent puis sont tout le
temps en train de chairlift août puis
moi je comparais les commentaires je
veux pas sur des groupes facebook pour
voir ce que les gens parlent de moi je
sais qu'il ya des gens qui même position
d'orange pour penser qu'ils pensent tout
le monde t'aime mais ma blonde elle l'a
fait pour aller débusquer
mais ce fait les gueux qui faisait sa
une vidéo qui va dire et c'est même pas
de raul
réjean de l'egypte bat toi toi t'es trop
belle à ma blonde amusé je ne sais même
pas drôle vidéo la même chose il ne m'a
pas si c'est un autre vidéo tout à
l'heure que le bébé allait contacter
site ici il marche que si c'est vrai que
ma paletou avant mes enfants continuent
à les regarder
il ya vraiment une différence entre un
commentaire bien articuler constructive
team est hantée bh juste cette semaine
en or cité des mails de gens qui ont
quitté mettront en désaccord certains
propos contenus dans un podcast pitié
expliquer pourquoi puis après ça c'est
comme au quai messages comme ceux pour
prendre en considération puis je veux
comme réfléchir à mes propres
agissements à voter et qui ce qui est ce
que vous faites est ce que c'est moi qui
dans l'erreur
c'est juste des n'empêche que met-on il
ya un questionnement avoir sur la
consommation sur amazon us
mais après ceux ci s'est dit d'une
manière respectueuse d'une manière
agressive tout se baissent pas
constructif ça mais c'est dit thomas tu
sais moi quelqu'un canada émet des
messages comme ce vraiment bien articulé
mais je fais questionner mes propres
agissements type saas et ceci
constructif mais y'a vraiment les deux
c'est certain mais cannes c'est paul qui
est ton propos je réponds comme ce
quelqu'un qu'il rencontrerait dans la
rue tu donc je vais m'acheter des
masques sur l'amazon un îlot de sa
boutique amazon stade diab château des
amis comme soute
t'as raison comme ça se peut que ça me
fasse ça fait réfléchir
ouais parce que quoi que tu fasses
tendaient des commentaires négatifs à
mener y en a qui m'avait j'avais pris un
hub à jeter rendu que
je te dirai en personne parce que je
prenais je connais dakar des crédits à
mark zuckerberg
ce sont les valets des fois ça peut
faire réfléchir quelques
je devrais pas prendre de but tu peux te
renseigner là dessus je peux encore
dehiba mais surtout les vegans sa touche
touche tellement large et ça touche à
l'environnement ça touche à l'éthique
animale sa touche à la santé
fake t on dirait que la qpc sur trois
fils est exposé totalement de fleurs fac
les après cela la marge d'erreur de
chose que tu peux faire encore et il y
en a un qui seraient pas d'accord
qu'est ce qui te fait parce que au
niveau entraînement andreu mental c'est
pas correct mais l'autre veut dire
niveau d'éthique animal puis l'autre
tacleur lopota santé votre critique
effet que si c'est tellement de chance
de tromper parce que c'est finalement sa
touche à tout mécanisme ce problème de
base c'est que les gens ici et idéalise
quinté sur c'est une personnalité pseudo
public s'agit d'enfants ce que je buvais
un coke diète une présentation
quelle erreur jean-michel non mais
sérieusement yeux du monde comme des
suds moelleux mais vous buvez du coquin
et oui je prends comme vous y êtes un
pote barentin
je suis déçu la veille et encourage une
multinationale qui qui qui qui est
néfaste est pas bon pour la savoie je
suis je sais tout ça mais je peux te
prendre la décision quand même de me
prendre une canette de liqueur une fois
de temps en temps tu y compris le temps
qu'on va idéalisé les gens piqué souvent
les influenceurs essaie de montrer une
espèce d'image de perfection ça peut
jouer aussi
moi je sais j'essaie de montrer de
montrer comme suit je vends ma blonde et
même génétique on aurait pu très vite on
perd soudain dans ces produits des fois
m'appelle de la jadco manque c'est un
marché sur internet le parce que d'être
avec des gens qui me suivent les ait en
chemin il s'est coupé les cheveux tout
seul ça bac fait il ya des gens qui
essaient de se montrer parfait puis
c'est ce que si tu fais un moral à tout
le monde après ceux méjean ils vont peut
être pu tenter de faire la morale mais
nous aussi nous personnellement je veux
pas mourir loge à savoir arrêter de
manger de la viande c'est comme à ce que
je savais comment je pense pensais pas
en tordant le bras personnes qui vont
faire changer maternité c'est en
informant et ça c'est un bon point pi
c'est moi ce que tu dis là c'est quand
quant à partager des les screenshots des
gens que tu écrivais pour amazon le tgt
écrivent les fat man ccd belleti ce
genre de commentaire là parce que
évidemment moi aussi je m'expose à super
puis j'en reçois beaucoup qu'ils savent
c'est sa maman a amené ça m'a amené au
point où est ce que je me suis dit ok je
vais arrêter de justes tout montrer ce
que je fais ou de montrer qui je vais
cibler qu'est ce que je veux montrer où
est ce que je sais que je tends contrôle
de ce que je montre et puis ça je sais
pertinemment que probablement parce que
c'est une minorité bruyante qui est qui
écrit ce genre de commentaire là puis je
sais que ça ça va nuire
a dû - probablement que plein de monde
qui aimerait ça plus voir en détail et
tillie qu'est ce que je fais puis me
voir moi + moi mais juste à cause de ce
genre de commentaire là moi j'ai pris la
décision d'arrêter de le faire parce que
quand tu perds toute la spontanéité
moi c'est ce même écoute moi c'est ce
que je fais puis j'en ai plus beaucoup
effectivement dommage j'ai essayé au
début ça m'affecter plus demandé j'ai
fait une story dans mon auto gdba en
cuir c'est un choix que j'ai acheté avec
vega ça fait longtemps le jeu de jambes
c'est lui qui restait dans coupe je vais
pas penser à se moquer gepam justice
mais non mais si mon prochain changera
pas des banques eurent mais là je me
suis fait ramasser j'ai dit qu'est ce
que je fais je pourrai plus faire de
sport lui dans mon auto
medica ça va être plate si en agressant
surtout le temps puis on est en marche
toujours sur des oeufs
c'est pas toi manx deviennent des gueux
qui qui se met en scène en faisant
historique qui répète moi j'aime ce qu'a
justement les réseaux sociaux c'est fait
pour avoir une proximité une haute et
pas télévision lors d'un salon sa
personne ce faux pas que ça faut pour
pas perdre notre spontanéité non plus à
cause d'une minorité jeu puisque et
interagir des gens là que j'ai appris
assez tôt que si tu mates chicane avec
quelqu'un que rien que ça à faire dans
vie se chicaner ne soit perdre ton temps
c'est quelqu'un qui décrypte se voit les
gens qui veulent juste que qui veulent
juste mettre de l'eau sont de garde sur
le feu cependant que ces gens tu peux
pas gagner que des gens comme ça parce
qu'ils ont toute la semaine
non c'est ce exact exact c'est
impossible de sortir victorieux d'un
argumentaire sur facebook ou sur
instagram ça arrive jamais tu gagnes à
mais jamais jamais jesse à elle faisait
avec les terminales à la fête une
publication sur les l'industrie laitière
qui l'oeil comme une baguette une
influence heures des fermiers il a été
suivi par comme 30000 personnes puis à
montrer son style de vie de productrice
laitière dans son lit puis le elle alla
comme priant alors comme pris sur elle
de mener une guerrière pour diriger son
son public vers la publication de jessy
pi jesse était pas capable de laisser le
dernier mot à ce monde l'a fait sur la
sous la publication il y avait une
espèce de conversation d'à peu près 1000
messages de jusqu'à la mer 10 bracelets
piste est impossible de sortir de turbie
mais je disais à arrêter de faire ce
qu'elle a été prise de laisser le
dernier mot à cette industrie leur
métier
c'était une période où j'avais déjà
entendu je ne discute pas de casque
répétés des ventes en dessous justement
à radio qui avaient des études qui a été
fait là dessus de ces piquets dans une
argumentation sur facebook jamais après
5 commentaires il ya un des deux parties
qui a changé son opinion très active des
fois mais toi tu vas voir des personnes
qui se répondent plus après d'autres
commentaires le personnage phare qui je
m'excuse qui c'est vrai excuse moi
j'étais dans l'erreur
mais plus que ce ça veut dire que les
deux personnes n'ont absolument aucun
intérêt à questionner puis à changer
leurs opinions pigeât mais après 5
commentaires il l'argument là ça vaut la
peine d'avoir une argumentation
non c'est vrai c'est absurde c'est
absorbé des jeunes qui sait car des
problèmes mentaux
tu peux avoir un compte facebook est une
institution commission la sec et des
jets qui moi me demande déjà stockées
ils sont créés plusieurs comptes
il disait des affaires comme massa s'est
suicidé à cause de toi de tes c'est de
bloquer ces gens un petit peu partout ce
qui crée d'autres comme ça c'est très
désagréable qu'un ya des gens qui se
mettent à fabuler sur toi comme seul ça
pollue aussi après ce tir les gens qui
viennent sur ta page si justement
s'était fait attaquer par un saut à un
groupe de monde qui qui qui qui tempo
août et après ça c'est comme pour les
autres c'est comme les i se promener
dans les commentaires ci sera pas
mettons quelque chose de constructif que
le fan à lire des débuts des témoignages
de monde qui aime ce que tu fais ça
vachette comme de la pollution le cpie
non cessibles en jour le plan garde ça
m'arrive pas je fais partie des chanceux
parce que les gens ma communauté
c'est du monde super
je suis pas bienveillant et puis j'ai
pas de problème mon quotidien c'est
peut-être je pose ça joue le sexe la
personne je pose s'ajoute ce soit que
moi je jetais un lieu ça fait que je
réponds des vieux cachant qui vont
m'envoyer des des courriels puis qu'ils
expliquent des affaires comme ça ça
c'est sûr et certain faits inconsistants
un peu le vendre eux aussi mais quand
même
pis tu sais ça devient vraiment autour
du sein de de gérer des réseaux sociaux
puis prenant que tu sais de quoi je
parle
emmenez quand tu veux répondre à tout le
monde quand tu veux aussi compter que
tout est clean que tout reste c'est
somme toute dans le respect ça devient
vraiment un autre que moi je trouve
sauveur ont mis une quinzaine de ses
gardes et du contenu sur toutes les
plateformes essayer de gare de rester
actif d'essayer de répondre aux gens
décident répondre à mes messages pour
garder une communauté engagée
des fois ça m'apparaît comme un
tourbillon puis une espèce de montagne
qui est difficile à à grimper comment
est-ce que tu gères tout ça parce que tu
es quand même somme tout actif tu crées
du contenu tu réponds aux gens qui te
tue des trucs pour être capable de
rester focus ou stable dans tous
vraiment g300 1000 followers en anglais
aussi s'installer rémois ce sera plus 3e
tous deux fois en fait beaucoup plus de
monde que j'ai beaucoup de maintien
reste dans ton sujet c'est beaucoup
moins tu as beaucoup moins de troupes
soit une recette
ok c'est certain que si je mets de
l'huile dans ma recette yann bien guy
beauché olivier dribbles ses pouvoirs
pour la santé si je me dis ce que du
sirop d'érable n'occupe mentir c'est
sucré mais 55 ans dans ton sujet c'est
pas très controversé par une recette de
fromage en anglais ce kit est ce que tu
tues tu montre aussi jean philippe
rochât reste de beaux des chefs basse et
moi c'est la même personne certains qui
en anglais
oh ma langue maternelle ça fait qu'il
faut que je pense plus à mes
interactions ça me demande plus
d'énergie d'interagir en anglais mais en
anglais de la mafia du plant based night
ça c'est des gens qui sont vraiment axé
sur la santé à tout prix s'effectue en
france il ya main mais je trouve que
c'est moins pire en français c'était
parce que les gens connaissent mon style
pays sauf que je peux un freak lots de 5
mhz ou telle méthode mais en anglais
aussitôt que tu vaux maître rené guizien
comme de l'huile végétale le monde rit à
moitié des commentaires ça va être là
dessus parce qu'il ya une espèce
d'instinct encore avait gagné pour la
santé
je sais pas non c'est que c'est pas pour
ce il ya plusieurs raisons pour
lesquelles on veut devenir veille à la
règle est ce ça devient l'opic moi je
dis je réponds pas ces gens à lolo c'est
quelqu'un je suis une publication de lui
et c'est mauvais pour le peu que je
pourrai commencer explique écoutez
madame ces quatre portions je mets une
cuillère à soupe d'huile survient à
moins d'une cuillère à thé par médecins
s'affairent à quoi parce qu'après ça va
m'envoyer une étude qui a le poignet sur
facebook de la revue vichy pas quoi
qu'en vrai puis une nano qui va arriver
qu'un autre étude sur vos partitions et
des baux peut pas gagner comme si avec
ces gens là sont tellement campé dans
leur opinion était juste mieux les
salles et puis il me vient c'est là la
réponse
hf devrait être tellement 20% sous mes
impôts passé ce 15 mai de shell je
trouve ça trop salée mais pour la
qualité la quantité de sel me semble
me semblait trop qu'est ce que tu veux
mais je ne sais pas combien peut pas
mesurer avec une caméra vraiment avec un
ordinateur commis trop de 16 à 17 c pas
goûté le feq fait comment comment tu
t'es capable de gérer sur pour pas virer
fou toutes ces plates formes l'atout de
chaque contenu lui à tous et voilà face
c'est que t'as pas le choix d'être à
l'écouté de la communauté comme moi des
gens ça m'insulte quand je vois des gens
qui font des pauses juste pour créer la
bisbille pour créer de l'interaction
puissant en vente
c'est comme si tu te plait je te dise et
puis comment ça va oh ça va bien
continuer le moratoire est ce que
j'essaye de carmin faut quand même
garder en deux temps passe vite comme on
dit en anglais je te réponds d'acier des
gestes des médias sociaux c'est fabuleux
pour les gens qui ont vraiment des
questions il y en a qui ont des
questions et des gens qui m'écrivent de
l'épicerie il m'avait dit screenshots ne
fut que toute sa vie ça me fait plaisir
de répondre oui c'est lui non lui lui
trop ferme n'est pas assez ferme ça il
faut quand même que c'est moi juste
assez accessible il époque personne qui
va gérer mes réseaux sociaux jamais
parce que c'est des questions sur 20 qui
sont pertinentes les gens posent plus
mauvais des photos de leur sèche des
reportages faut quand même que tu suives
même moment donné si tu suis dit bon
côté tant rapport choix de subir des
mauvais les mauvaises critiques ou comme
je disais chanceux parce que les gens
seraient pas chez eux les jeunes
m'attaque pas sur mon physique il
m'attaque pas sûr très souvent je pense
que c'est pire pour les films sans aucun
d'eux est ce que tu es ce que tu
dénonces vegan qui s'échappe des
gencives et gagnent ça ne peut jamais à
cet échange et vhc les flux tabarka non
j'en ai pas je dirais que c'est plus des
vegan qui s'acharne sur moi et me disent
que je passais vegan à leur goût de ces
sources
parce que tu es ma vie mais c'est
vanessa qui tu t'adresses au site
s'adresse succès à l'extrait seo ou plus
et gagnent des vegan puis à cette
clientèle précise centre s'adresse à
toute personne qui est intéressé à
diminuer sa consommation de viande puis
cuisiner des recettes et ghantou adresse
à tout le monde monsieur madame tout le
monde parce qu'ils m'insultent c'est
quand quelqu'un arrive sur ma page plein
de bonnes intentions paix dit ouais j'ai
décidé d'arrêter de devenir végétarien
puis je sais de l'encourager puis les
divisions qui se rabat sur l'ubs qui
disent oui mais l'objet tard y est c'est
pire que pas être vegas est pire qu est
omnivore parce que tu manges dut ont peu
de süskind mais le pompon pu commencer
encourager les gens qui font un effort
vain de condamner toujours peut regarder
la bête noire pizza c'est sur wii la
personne continuait à manger des oeufs
tel qu'un moment donné quand à votre
rendu doivent arrêter d'en manger nous
pour l'instant à fait déjà un effort
c'est un fait de jeu d'efforts de pas
manger de viande la semaine attend le
car était de partir de là bsb d'essayer
de fait le mouvement avait gagné gros
problème de communication je pense je
pense que je pense que tu le bien dit
j'écoutais j'écoute et on vous écoute
avec minutes ensuite joue puis tu
parlais que tu avais fait passionnant à
mamoudzou
oui je sais d'enfants pour ceux qui nous
écoutent qui savent pas c'est quoi ces
onze jours en silence si tu en joues ces
dix jours mais théoriquement arrive la
veille ça fait que c'est comme un onze
jours c'est un dix jours un silence un
silence complet nation silencieuse d'un
ce c'est en cours de méditation comme
c'est une retraite de méditation puis
toi tu méditer avant oui c'est à 20 je
pense important de mai dit un petit peu
à 20 200 voix pour faire une course de
vélo quand on jamais plus fait pas le
tour de france n'a jamais fait du vélo
nos qu'elles font l'homme autant que
c'est long c'est déjà long comme un
petit peu d'expérience
est ce qu'ils étaient organisme sans but
lucratif qui est à montebello puis dans
tout les pays un type en tout le pays ce
court ça s'appelle vipassana puis on
peut faire un ding peut le faire rien
aux états unis en a partout voilà tu
t'inscris en ligne c'est gratuit mais en
partant tulle est ce que tu veux pour la
prochaine personne
c'est un petit peu du pays pour le
suivant je peux laisser sa pièce
connaissait de sainte paule et c350
scène si tu veux personne qui va qui va
savoir que tu a régné le site fait que
tu arrives là tu t'installes ces dix
heures de méditation par jour bâle a dit
joe wright silencieuse ce que si jamais
te dis demain les a pas que tu essayes
de fruits qui est opposé à vos surfaces
écouta motivation aller l'oeil et il est
une raison pour laquelle mon père
l'avait fait ok le moment pas c'est
quelqu'un qui est assez pragmatique mais
beaucoup de scientifiques qui font ces
méditations le lui avais dit c'est parce
que moi je veux vieillit j'ai peur de
perdre mes capacités je vire un pep il
était plus capable maintenant de
déblayer sakho ce qui dit jour voir si
je perds tout ce que j'ai toutes mes
repas commence que je veux réagir puis
le but de les laisser aussi d'observer
sans juger j'observe je mange pas quand
tu veux labo t'observe avoir commencé
coutts a fait avoir faim c'est quand aux
femmes peut pas ouvrir latérite peut pas
regarder ton cellulaire cet objet de
t'asseoir les yeux fermés pendant trois
heures de temps la fin tu te rends
compte que amante et à dessein à vient
rapport c'est que c'est pareil pour la
douleur quand et ascione indien depuis
un an
[ __ ] ça tâter lance dans le dos dans
jambes d'un genou
bah tu te rends compte que la douleur
c'est quelque chose qui vient pierre
parent c'est pas constant ceci peau
comme s'était déployée sur 220 la
douleur puis disent que si toute la
douleur qu'elle paraissait de l'observer
sans juger avec tap certes c'est quoi si
tu peux le satyre ça brûle ça chauffe ça
pique ça qu'est ce que ça fait c'est que
la méditation c'est beaucoup c'est le
contraire de la
assez positive à penser positif c'est de
se dire oh je m'imaginais que ça va ça
va changer ma manière d'être
la méditation ces deux jeunes arrêtés je
suis présentement je vais observer dans
qui les touche lui puis un moment donné
tu observes tellement que ça disparaît
boutons clic sur ouette tu connais carl
saucier bouffard jean philippe quignon
preuve d'éthique animal collège dawson
points puis un luxe c'est lui qui m'a
parlé de tss en premier en fait puis
deux puis ça a toujours été ça toujours
piqué ma curiosité
moi j'ai jamais fait de méditation de
dunes ma vie mais ça fait plusieurs
personnes
dernièrement je dd quand même des
problèmes de gestion de stress j'ai
beaucoup de choses à penser beaucoup de
choses qui m'occupait puis j'ai pour la
première fois de ma vie fait des dix
épisodes de stress intense le sens d'une
attaque de panique parce que je ne sais
pas si tu es réellement sûr mais des
vrais épisodes de stress intense j'en ai
perdu des cheveux puis c'était vraiment
y puis pilote ça fait beaucoup de monde
que je dors dix autres équipes qui me
parle de méditation puis c'est quelque
chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup et on
avait un ami qui était mon coloc pendant
pendant un an à québec fils puis fils
lui est allé thaïlande qui je pense que
c'est un talon qui avait fait 27 jours
on se languit puis lui ce qu'ils
disaient c'est que un moment donné je
pense que c'est après la 7e journée où
il était juste plus capable pitié il
s'est mis à pleurer incontrôlable mans
puis apprécier comme uhh uhh comme
réussi à remonter la pente puis d'y
avant la fin j'étais capable de
de me sortir de moi même qui doit
observer méditer et à 6 puis il se
voyait méditer qu'ils étaient capables
de 2 comme tu disais de daube d'observer
ce qu'est ce qui se passe en danse lui
qui suit assure qu'un qu'on habitait
ensemble
souvent je rentrais dans l'appartement
toutes les lumières étaient fermés fait
que je pensais que têtue elle joue vraie
lumière puis fils est au milieu du salon
dans le noir total plie ouvrez les yeux
pied il me salue et puis lui il était
résident en médecine à ce moment là puis
il disait que ça allait vraiment
beaucoup
quand il y avait des horaires de pas
possible puisque depuis que sa vie
allait trop vite c'est à juste ralentir
la vie pu observer qu'est ce qu'ils
ressentent et c'est quoi le stress
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui amène le stress
puis une fois que tu relative et ça
j'imagine que c'est beaucoup plus facile
de le rationaliser puis de le gérer
est-ce que ce que tu utilises un petit
peu comme ça puis six mois mais ton je
veux commencer à me informés ou à m'y
intéresser
qu'est ce que tu me suggère qu est ce
que tu ferais l'important c'est ce qu'on
apprend dans le bouddhisme et puis dans
la méditation parce que le maître tout
méditation et des racines bouddhiste le
mind fournissent tous à tout des racines
bouddhiste ce qu'on apprend c'est
l'équanimité sais que c'est pas les
événements c'est pas c'est pas des
situations qui font que tu vas souffrir
c'est la manière dont est perçue et
c'est un hamster mental qui par la
preuve des gens qui ont tout ce qui veut
dire note en occident sinon on m'aura
pas trop en personne tu te sois chez
vous puisque mais c'est le scénario
catastrophe
amelia qu'est ce qui va arriver qu'est
ce qui va m'arriver semaine prochaine
puis là encore plus quand on est en
confinement comme ceux que la vie va
reprendre son cours car quand tu médites
observe ce cd vague ça arrive ça va ça
vient ça l'un pays ksar des saints une
fois que tu es rendu compte que tout un
pays puis tout redescendre en vie la vie
est plus facile mais sauf que tu
t'arrêtes pour observer ce en méditation
tant par le choix de l'endurer
le pic le pic de douleurs physiques le
pic d'anxiété
le pic de douleur mentale le pic de
telemann et c'est boring même si c'est
vraiment plate
ça monte top sauf que ça monte ça
atteint plateau observe que c'est un
plateau t'observe que chaque dessin puis
c'est un entraînement menteur comme cet
entraîneur faire du marathon mais tendre
un ton esprit ce que tu peux faire pour
commencer la méditation et rien qui plus
simple que ça bienvenue qui est plus
difficile
ça faisait que tu te souhaite
confortablement le dos droit en 1 10 ou
sur une chose observe le souffle observe
sa respiration de se concentrer sur une
seule chose ta respiration ça peut être
la sensation de haut niveau de tes
narines
ça pète on abdomen il ya toutes les fois
que ton esprit par pis ma vagabond de
mardi ce qu'on va manger pour super
survient ta respiration c'est sur le
muscle la méditation
c'est ce qui procure une détente un
moment donné dans ta vie tous les jours
sixt muscles os il y devient plus
développés pis tu arrêtes de thé par
pied à gauche à droite dans des
scénarios catastrophes pierre c'est sûr
plein contrôle sur groupe ton esprit
puis tu t'appelles pendant la méditation
quand tu es rendu un certain niveau ton
subconscient iprocess des affaires aussi
ceci quand tu aimerais tu te rends
compte que tu sors de là avec pas mal
moins pas un quinté rente et ton
attitude a changé parce que t'as pas un
chouette confrontées certaines pensées
et des gens que ça se manifeste au
niveau physique qui vont pleurer ils
vont regarder des crises et des gestes
au niveau physique ils vont avoir des
douleurs incroyable puis une fois qu'on
pourrait cesser la pensée qui était
rattachée à cette douleur le ca vaut
mieux une chose est certaine quand on
sort d'une retraite de méditation moi
j'ai vu des gens j'ai vu des délinquants
sortir de l'eau
je reconnaissais pas
journée on arrive on a droit de parler
on rencontre des gens agence guy hoquet
le caractère de tellement la dernière la
dernière journée car tu te remet à
parler avec les gestes ces deux
personnes différentes
en dix jours c'est incroyable mais
c'était face il y avait beaucoup plus de
monde qui fait la méditation générique
faisait très très justement piste un peu
ceux qui sont constitués justement ce
qui s'est passé c'est que la peur de sa
vie quand même assez difficile seppi
nous y avait des choses qui kills qu'il
pesait qu'il travaillait qui étaient là
enfoui en lui et qui est qu'ils
n'avaient même pas connaissance et si
par la méditation
après des jo en cela justement qui s'est
rendu compte que ces choses le
complètement enfouis rejaillissait qu'il
est justement lui citer ces tests et des
journées à pleurer et des journées avoir
des réactions physiques d'espagne super
jusqu'à ce que ça passe et après ça
c'est comme acquis et quelque chose
qu'ils quittaient règle et épicé aussi
de ce qui expliquait ses 2,6 et des
femmes de toutes ces départs on parle de
dépendance aux débuts de podcasts il pas
seulement à l'alcool la drogue et toutes
les choses vraiment addictif méthylé on
est tous des parts d'air à un million
d'affaires dans notre ville et
indépendant nos téléphones et bien sûr
indépendant à tout ce qu'on fait au
quotidien je dire on est tellement
d'action comprend de manière
inconsciente monde chose qu'on fait à
tous les jours sans mandat en compte le
ski on se défait de tout se fait
absolument rien à porsche au mans être
pleinement conscients de ce que tu fais
être concentré sa respiration be
après ça s'est calmé quand des faits de
tout les millions milliards des stimuli
qu'on a tout le temps après ça mais
après tout est le mot je rends compte
que murray ce qui me raconte m après
jean philippe pour eux était un acquis
et c'est ou non ce que je dis mais après
ce un petit coup de 20 reprises je dois
être là sentir tellement plus
intensément quelque chose d après ce qu
atre vous revenez en ta vraie vie
cette action chaque petite chose un
comportement aussi qu'on ne tue pas dans
l'inconscient entre petit veau justement
a fortement de recul j'ai l'impression
sur toutes ces petites choses là qu'on
fait
après après après si je te vends du site
dépendant
parler reda chami blonde assise assez
après ça c'est comme acquis
mais conscient petites rencontres issus
de toutes les petits détails du
comportement ce même facile de défendre
aussi des mauvaises des mauvais plis
mauvaise habitude j'ai l'impression
entièrement raison me disent que quand
tu fais une retraite de méditation et à
des réponses à des questions que tu aies
jamais posée c'étaient des choses qui
arrivent tout y voir et je me rappelle
des affaires que j'ai vécu quand j'étais
enfin comment ça c'est ça sort douze
puis j'ai pas su ce que c'est de
s'asseoir à silence pendant 10 jours
sans parler sans communiqué mettant
process des choses
une chose est certaine quand tu sors de
l'eau et beaucoup plus humain est
beaucoup plus patient avec les gens
quelqu'un tu es rentré sa première chose
que j'ai remarqué que ma blonde au ciel
leurs marques et se jeter rendu beaucoup
plus calme puis beaucoup moins impulsif
c'est sûr je me sentais de dix jours de
cela soit faisable mais ça fonctionne
vraiment les gens qui se rencontrent là
bas beaucoup d'ingénieurs beaucoup de
gens très cartésien c'est pas un achat
ou ce que des esprits puis d'être ici
pour moi je suis allergique à seulement
c'est la pensée magique que j'étais
secret' des affaires comme seul le chu
c'est le contraire de ce c'est juste
d'observer la réalité comme et les
saints se met un paquet d'histoires sans
attache un paquet d'histoires et de quoi
je vais avoir l'air puis si je fais ce
puits qu'est ce que les autres vont pas
s'épuiser que tu devrais amassant tiona
va après de cette retraite le tir sorti
de l'ept tour marquez une différence de
juin changement - changements qui
s'opèrent certains mettaient pas besoin
de faire une retraite en partant pour
avoir un changement qui s'opère entre
viamedis tente juste en sorte commence
par cinq minutes par jour commence par
dix minutes par jour
damiens était capable de faire une demi
heure de méditation le sans bouger à 6
des prêts pour faire une retraite comme
tout d'après moi aussi ma tante est
capable de faire 1 20 minutes je te
dirai qui tu es capable de faire 20
minutes deux fois par jour des prêts à
aller dans une dans une retraite comme
ça une retraite du personnes ça n'a
jamais fait ta vie ça se peut que je
trouve sarov les premières journées il
faut quand même que tu es au début la
méditation se trouvait sa position de
méditation aussi qui est difficile moi
j'ai une espèce de petit bain que je me
suis pas tenté avec des coussins que je
sais comment est ce que je suis je
conforte très bluesy comme c'est comme
un vélo c'est comme n'importe quoi faut
qu il a juste le bien et est en retraite
de méditation ce pôle teinte dans la
course les spots à la marche est tombé
six âgées rappelle du projet bécik
équipe le plus haut jamais en tête
baissée man band comprend des sketches
immédiate à tous les jours encore tout
le temps est-ce que tu as une routine
qui est établie ouais je sais de mehdi
teale matin andrée que quand tu as
commencé ta journée c'est plus difficile
de méditer parce que le teddy bear je
prends un break pour méditer j'ai
d'autres choses à faire après tu prends
juste ce que tu as à faire
souvent c'est mieux de méditer y en a
qui aiment sommet dite et le soir il y
en a qui aiment ça mais dit-il matin ça
dépend de la personnalité puis attend me
dit le cpo pour maître de musique latine
il ya des gens qui pensent les
méditations se met la musique puis non
c'est pour qu'amazon sport nature
j y pense le mythe de thèmes méditation
c'est galvaudé faut méditer là dessus
non mais dites et c'est pas avec des
ding ding que des bombes guidées du
tam-tam sept contrats des chants
grégoriens
c'est le contrat que je sais pas de
musique c'est plate à éclater mais à mon
ado net atteint un niveau bien née
ça devient le fan moi de nous la
méditation est ce que les que le bus est
passé à rien aussi de laisser venir qu
est ce qui vient c'est quelque chose qui
se passe dans quelqu'un te dépasser à un
moratoire ou et je fais tout ce petit à
soi ou ou de la cause est ce qui est
foutu les néophytes chasse cette pensée
les utiliser penser que thales allait
vous pétez c'est d'arrêter pensivement
des dépenses et moi je me dis que j'en
ai dépensé qui vont arriver mon repos il
va arriver sera pas bon signe
sauf que tu es tu l'étiquette jeudi à
une passe
thales allait comme comme un nuage dans
un ciel tout est le ciel puis la pensée
c'est une image à la bezole mais ces
nuages nuage rspo l'île depuis qu'on a
commencé à se parler ni manger bouger
c'est fluide permanente surréaliste que
tout était pour l'image des le ciel
c'est un caniveau puis la vie à bien ce
vient écrire des affaires dante est
peut-être le choix des croix rousse poli
croix puis tu prends du recul mais tu
découvre qu'il ya une espèce de centre
dans toi tu peux être sans entrer en jeu
pour avoir toutes ses pensées le khitaï
reste c'est possible suffit de
l'entraîneur suffit de se pratiquer mais
la méditation cdci découvre qu est ce
qui est en dessous des pensées c'est
quoi votre niveau
qui est le saas est stable puis ça c'est
pas angoissé ça c'est pas des primes un
sas a fait preuve crises d'anxiété
c'est c'est un cintre là dessus la vie
vient dessinée dépenses et puis ya des
choses qui arrivent mais plus que tu
t'habitues dans méditation à laisser
passer les pensées quand et puant
méditation ton défaut par défaut ce vote
va avoir acquis cette capacité de
laisser passer des choses se fait quand
quelqu'un souhaite dans le trafic puis
va t'envoyer promener
ça va de penser que ces recrues comme
d'euros sur le dos d'un canard ça c'est
drôle quand tu réalises un moment donné
dit carline j'ai changé parce que dans
des moments stressants la méditation qui
embarque quant aux moments angoissants
c'est un background de méditation qu'un
bac
tu as tout le monde en parle cette
méditation car barque
c'est honteux reading à bac 5 ce drame
quand on prend ce quintet chimique table
en que c'est ton choix unique des
méditations qu'en bas c'était cette
espèce de pelo qui était réussi à
entraîner comme un muscle payer tout le
temps lui tout le temps avec toute
excuse une retraite comme ceux skis
premièrement commence à fond est ce que
te ment dans une grande pièce où chacun
a son qui excuse est ce qu'il ya un
coaching est ce que ce que tu te faire
enseigner comment bien méditer ou c'est
vraiment juste arrive le silence
go home et it tarif bleu tu peux parler
jusque jusqu'au soir où on se couche le
t2 par chambre souvent si tu veux
vraiment pas deux par chambre de mardi
une chambre seule la personne de ce
moment là on instruit redonne une place
dans une grande pièce de méditation les
hommes sont séparés des fins peut-être
sans sommes d'abord 100 femmes de
l'autre cô toient potes et croisera
jamais fait une grande salle de
méditation on attribue une place au
hasard dans salle de méditation que ça
va être ta place tu as ton cousin de
tintin au tibet type de servir le petit
peu dérangé comme souvent pour être
confortable rester dans sa chambre avec
l'autre personne ne t'as pas le droit de
communiquer
ça fait que taper louadah regarder
l'autre personne c'est comme s'ils
vivaient de défaut est un petit muret de
rien entre les deux personnes se
voyaient le début me donne souvent une
autre personne dans ta chance il parle
pas mais ça devient tellement naturel de
pau communiqué que ça tu penses que pas
par la taille de les drisses haluchère
bien on commence à votre copain le dans
ta bulle d'autun aura très strictes et
en fait ces méditations la prison
c'était plus strict s'ils avaient
aménagé pour les méditations que les
prisons en général de l'acfas une
section plus stricte la prison dans juno
sse relève me dit de 4 à 6 à 16 ans je
connais pas l'heure exacte mais je pense
et quatre à cinq et demi après ceux du
deuxième 6 à 7 après sorte surtout ne me
fait pas la une en tentant les bleus
soir il ya des vidéos qui t'explique
jour après jour quoi prêtre quoi
travailler qui t'expliquent comme un
mythe et ses locks une formation qui est
important que ce soit des vidéos parce
que c'est pour l'interprétation du
professeur et un professeur qui est
l'autre peut le consulter
mais c'est pas son interprétation à lui
sinon ça changerait tout le temps les
vidéos c'est pour que ce souhait
standard international maintenant avec
eux se situent pas les voir professeur
moi j'avais très très mal en jambes ce
que j'ai dit qu'est ce que je fais je
peux avoir une chaise digard je te
conseille d'essayer encore une journée
si jamais tu étais vraiment encore mal
on va te donne une chance
finalement ça avait passé manière assez
miraculeuse mais tu peux aller voir le
professeur tad et des repos deux repas
par jour après midi dimanche peau
jusqu'au lendemain owens et à première
séquence est ton premier séjour de dix
jours je peux manger des fruits puis
boire du thé le soir à moins qu'ils
aient une condition particulière c'est
une condition particulière ils se
battront pas avec tous en avoir des tons
cela soit c'est pas une prison mais pas
ce point lui quand dirais même que c'est
à ben franchement je n'ai pas mon truc
encore plus le chemin après le camp
maritime cma jaloux des gens que c'est
leur deuxième séjour puis deux autres
images pas du tout mais ceci dit si tu
veux manger du porc puis et quelquefois
quand t'as pas manger tu as mangé une
pomme depuis la veille depuis le midi la
veille la torre déjeuner y ait bondi
cette levée g7 ou végétariens vegan
c'est une question que je voulais poser
parce que
j'ai parlé à quelqu'un qui fait ça pas
mal
un ami à moi qui m'a dit beaucoup
puisque depuis que commencer à méditer
il ya vraiment est rapproché de du
véganisme sans être vegan maintenant ils
végétarien 100 % puis il ya ces poules
il fait venir ses pôles y habitaient
dans le nord il fait il ne s'est pas
livrée sur pied
puis lui dixon se rapprocher de lui puis
comprendre
lui disait comprendre sa place dans sur
la planète puis sa place surtout la
place de sa conscience dans certains
dans son propre corps et ses salles à
beaucoup rapproché du véganisme puis de
7,7 penser là d'essayer d'être le plus
possible
un symbiose avec la planète est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est pourquoi est
ce que ces deux affaires sont liées
pourquoi est ce que dans justement
j'aimerais faire comme ça cvg qui dans
dans la vie les gens souvent qu'ils sont
bouddhistes ont tendance à être plus
végétariens et vegan c'est parce que le
bouddhisme ces deux postes créés et de
souffrance veut pas dans ce cours de
méditation le sait pas un cours sur le
bouddhisme et miss a des racines
bouddhiste ça fait que ont fait il ya
une méditation qu'on fait à chaque fois
qu'on finit notre méditation qui
s'appelle métaux salle aquitaine mais
c'est d'envoyer de l'amour et tout le
monde sait ça à la cud main mais c'est à
fanta méditation dit ok je dois prendre
mes amis je vous la renvoyez de l'amour
à mes amis pressé faut que tu envoies de
l'amour à quelqu'un qui est notre cas
précis c'est le bout de publicis et
avril de l'amour est quelqu'un que tu
ailles ya bien d affaire qui sort
surtout d'avis mais de t'asseoir année
10h07 recul je voyais envoyer la mairie
en réparer lui mais ça fait du bien
parce que qu'appareil promener quelqu'un
la première personne que tu fais
souffrir c'est tout ce qui se raconte
aussi taxés normal que c'est normal ça
soit vg la boue qui est pas devient pas
ce qui fait souffrir des êtres vivants
ne pas se poser de faire souffler des
êtres vivants puis moi je suis retourné
souvent comme bénévole pour faire de la
cuisine la bo de la panacée jaune et
laisse des chances ou ceux qui sont
tombés par hasard sur jean-philippe ce
rire qu'il arrivait je voulais marquer
le 10ème été postposée mais la première
fois qu'il ya une araignée pu taper loin
de là dessus et c'est vrai que je freine
a régné sans raison c'est l'arrêt mis à
revivre la preuve c'est que tu essaies
de l'écraser assauts répétés ce à tous
les ied sur la terre par ça ne veut
souffrir même ton ennemi nous le truc tu
lui envoyer de l'amour tu n'es pas
capable veut plus souffrir que tout
prendra qui est un truc qui parce qu'ils
souffrent aussi
mais ça ce pauvre il s'offre
il s'offre la première personne que tu
fais souffrir qu'un tube
qu'est ce qu'on s'est torché hausse est
due comme beach est un peu de sport d'un
bric soit l'éditeur japonais nikon 1 à
1,5 à la toile à tous
[Musique]
vachon
excusez c'était la livraison
hebdomadaire de kombucha assez comme
tout le monde c'est hot tuer
est-ce que c'est lui qui t'a envoyé
surtees a commandé non il venu apporter
parce que j'ai fait une star avec ce
gâteau est lui venu m'apporter nascar au
sol
je crie aujourd'hui tout le monde mais
riche plus de ça les deux parties du
cerveau est écouté hier
en fait je suis à la fête des story
c'est compagnie québécoise préférée de
compagnie et éthique québécoise préférée
puis le saf une semaine deux seuls plats
pas changé ses adresses encore fait que
je reçois tout de suite non alors su
infinie de stock lé genre des colliers
des colis des colis de d'objets gratuits
son adresse au public non sauf que dans
le fond c'est des compagnies de fonds en
fac d avec des barres fait avec notre
note agents qui notamment ils ont volé
du tout gratuit de notre passage
je suis je suis fasciné en passant par
ma conversation banale fond c'est ça
était en train d'expliquer pourquoi
est-ce que le véganisme cette pensée lot
n'était pas faire de mal aux autres
comment est-ce que ces deux choses ne
sont liés puis je pense que tu l'avais
bien expliqué en disant que c'est juste
de ne pas faire de mal pis puisque cette
idée là depuis que je suivais gagnent
parce que le sac
ça commence à faire un petit bout ça
commence à faire ses proches proches
trois ans déjà proches mon anniversaire
le 3 puis
puis on dirait que depuis que je suivais
gagnent je le sent un peu seul me sens
mieux par rapport à la planète j'aime
pas plus nécessairement les animaux
parce que moi je suis pas invité j'ai
jamais été un fan d'animaux j'ai jamais
vraiment un métier première manche est
allergique aux chiens puis au chu pitié
je veux dire ça jamais été une des
choses si j'ai pas besoin je ressens pas
le besoin d'avoir un animal avec moi
sauf que de savoir que
fais pas de souffrance
ou que j'en crée moins je me sens
vraiment mieux avec cette idée là
au quotidien
je pense que si sucre et la souffrance
d'une manière directe c'est le ressentir
et plus de sucres et la souffrance était
obligé de les égorger un cochon pour
manger je voudrais c'est le raid en face
à rochus cris de souffrance
tandis que si quelqu'un d'eau qu'il fait
pour toi tu as l'impression que tu crées
moins de souffrance mais je pense qu'au
niveau 1 contient est encore de la
soufflante
je pense que ça reste l'assurance parce
qu'au niveau inconscient de souci je
suis un geek pas un animal qui est mort
le pour qu'ils puissent manger avec
c'est pas parce que c'est pas tant
qu'ils le tuent et de la souffrance et
paul houde qui une fois que cheikh
une fois que le déclic effet dans ta
tête ça devient tellement plus difficile
à regarder pierre
à être conscients que certaines actions
sont précités je donne l'exemple souvent
d'hommes quinconces en parle le ty
combien de fois est ce que j'ai vu un
camion rempli de port avant d'être vegan
ils me supportent rien dit c'est dit
depuis que le déclic s'est fait quand je
vois ce camion leur puis je vois leur
museau à travers les qui rit et sam des
colis complètement qui est dernièrement
jean philippe de partager une photo sur
facebook deux je crois que c'était renan
la rue que partager la photo que c'est
un port en fait dans une porcherie qui
était pas capable de se tenir sur ses
pattes parce que l'enclos était pas
assez haut mais pas capable d'être
complètement couchés
parce que l'enclos n'était pas assez
large
pis qui était le puits qui se faisait
traiter par ses porcelets à travers un
grillage puis j'ai vu ça puisse à lui ça
le sa mauléon licharre d'europe et des
cours est tellement ça m'a mis sur le
cul une voix hors celui qui la cause
l'éthique animale c'est pas c'est pas la
chose je pense que c'est toi j'en fume
seulement qu'ils disent est la cause de
l'éthique animale c'est parce qu'il ce
qui t'amène véganisme nécessairement
mais c'est ce qui te fait rester là j'ai
l'impression
oui parce qu'un animal qui est maltraité
un animal man au niveau de la santé ce
cas toutes les trois semaines une
nouvelle mode là quand tu sais pas qui
est aussi d'autres choses avec le
véganisme x10 est bon il n'existe pas
bon et en a qui sort qui sont son
contenu et en actions pour ça mais une
fois que tu as intégré que le camp pour
manger de la viande faut que l'animal y
meurt puis que tu peux pas mort et sans
souffrir même si des gens prétendent
qu'on les tue d'une manière humaine
l'animal il veut pas mourir
une fois que tu intégrer ce il y en a
plus de tuning bâcle n'y pense plus
c'était vraiment renverser son mode de
pensée
tu dis un tel point tu dis comment j'ai
pu pour manger de la viande en est ces
années le
c'est complètement absurde parce que ton
ton niveau tontouta pensée a tellement
viré 360 que c'est absurde pour tous
d'avoir des gens mangent de la viande
pour tourner une bande puis sur la
méditation s'arrête pour ça parce que ça
ralentit citons schèmes de pensée
puis
plus que tu médites plus que tu te rends
compte que est un trou de cul avec les
gens ça t'amène drapeau bonheur face
offrir les autres reset revivent à 7mn
europe en a fait le jouet ce compresseur
ou l'instant quand tu manges un space ou
quand avait promené quelqu'un dans le
trafic mais c'est pas ce qui fait que tu
es un bon à ce poste un abord comme on
dit en anglais c'est pas durable qui
était mieux d'investir sur un bonheur
durable que sur des plaisirs éparpillés
à gauche qu'à droite
absolument et j'allais justement dit
quelqu'un qui veut commencer l'oeuvre
jeudi à une spéculation mais je vais
commencer la méditation
ces lieux du tuteur de d'applications
pisseux est ce que ça peut être un bonne
porte d'entrée d'après toi ou tes
minutes mais au téléphone le plus loin
possible de recommencer
non tu peux commencer par des
méditations guy deuil des apps qui
s'appelle comme il ya des apps et
plusieurs applications le cadet mais dit
au début mais le plus vite possible
surpoids s'affranchir de ce mieux ça va
être
c'est sûr qu'au début mon cas j'ai
commencé mes dit et je fréquente un
centre bouddhiste ou ce qui avait
quelqu'un qui nous dicte qui nous
expliquait tiago qui avait constaté vous
sur votre respiration puis temps en
temps nous rappelait de se concentrer
sur notre respiration c'est une bonne
chose parce que le tt vraiment partie le
tout joué au baseball
mais le plus vite possible tu vas
arriver à affranchir de ces applications
le plan lecture des contraintes du sida
ou de paradoxal en forme pour mon
téléphone une source de des stress quand
même le tpiy justement quand tu veux
mais dit et tu veux essayer de réduire
ton niveau d'anxiété va clés de la voix
dans votre téléphone juste à côté qui
peut avoir un message qui rendent le
n'importe quoi
khadad tcd méditer ça me paraît un petit
peu contre 2,706 contre contre intuitif
mais la méditation c'est aussi si tu
médites automatiquement il va avoir du
bruit en ville chauvin le ce qui vaut
rien oiseaux moment donné
je dois pas attendre avant de commencer
à méditer le monde it was all ces
sources tout commence à méditer vient
s'installer ce bord de la fenêtre mais
la méditation c'est ça aussi c'est
d'apprendre dirais avec l'oiseau c'est
d'apprendre dirais que la mouche qui
vient se poser sur cette attaque était
tout le temps la même moto dimanche
c'est accéder au site aussi d'observer
ce sens jugé c'est d'observer les
oiseaux sans juger c'est d'observer la
mouche sans juger c'est d'observer qu'il
ya peut-être un message qui va rentrer
son téléphone puis je sors de pat vieira
chez pourra regarder ces qui s'est déjà
déjà un travail
ce travail et on musculeux terme une
méditation victoire des choses qui est
qu'après leur culte et de la méditation
justement temps apparaît tantôt mecque
des trucs qui lui qui nous dérangeait ou
qui te déranger pic après si tu dis
c'est tellement absurde que cette
affaire le maté nier de ces techniques
sont dérangés parce qu'il aime pas la
coiffure avec 36 à terville
seoul 3 domaines skies drôle parijs
caméra sur d'être affectés dérangés par
des choses aussi banales été anodine
mais ça c'est ton hamster qui parle
ce sont ces hamsters qui court dans ta
tête puis qui juge tout le monde puis
qui regarde puis qu'il soit pas dans
leur super gars dit d'entrée par garde
la dent lui par garda dans l puis je
serai jamais aussi bon que ça ou sont
meilleurs que moi meilleur que dans tout
autre et c'est tout ce que tu calmes at
il dit
parce que tu te concentres sur ta
respiration qui laisse aller ses pensées
l'occitan réussi à les laisser avec un
timide dans ta vie toujours ça va
devenir ça va devenir farfelu moi je me
suis rendu compte dans le trafic
j'étais vraiment impôts
bon pour me calmer le pompon anatole
ouest
j'avais tendance le poids de la vitesse
pièce vraiment frustré que la greffe et
ça c'est quelque chose tu remarques
après tu dis waouh je tourne autour des
fois la radio même pas ouverte à mme un
peu de musique torrentspy ça fait une
demi heure que je roule je n'ai pas un
sens puis je sui bate
ce qui est magnifique aussi secte
atteint un niveau de bien-être
si tu pratiques la ministation régulière
mais tu atteins unis tant au niveau ton
stendhal c'est ton ton niveau le par
défaut ils vont être plus calme qu'avant
d'hommes dans ce que tu viens de dire
est quelque chose qui m'est qui m'est
apparu conjointement au raisonnement du
niveau de bien-être puis la fille ou la
personne qui se fâche par rapport à la
coiffure de véronique cloutier
par exemple pour faire le lien avec
nommé pour faire le lien avec ce que
disait au début c est par rapport aux
médias sociaux quelqu'un qui qui
s'insurge contre n'importe quoi
puis que met-on d'être capable de
prendre un deux minutes pour réaliser
que
ce sale aucun impact
ça sert à rien d'en parler
puis juste de réfléter si tout le monde
pouvait faire ce travail-là demi depuis
je suis le premier à paul fort le mes de
recentrer sur qu'est ce qui réellement
important pendant qu est ce que je
devrais mettre de l'énergie
on s'en sortirait tout vraiment mieux
j'ai l'impression que le fait de
s'insurger contre laquelle la coiffure
de ne pas pratiquer sa foi et celle
d'énergie les cirques un fétichisme du
barbier rendez vous ça dure pas
longtemps
c'est ça qu'on se rend compte aussi
quand on me dit c'est tout un début tout
un plateau tout or dessin je fais quand
un commentaire de marc d'un peu sur
internet dit ok ça tenait ses succès
devient pas un simple tu deviens paulo
un touriste dérange
ça devient pas indifférent tout sauf que
s'ouvre montée sus que ça sent à vous
tous et que ça va redescendre dix
minutes après tes carré est parfait
emprunt
je reste jeune observé ça c'est déjà
c'est déjà beau je restais moi mon livre
des conseils pratiques pour être honnête
dit au début si la plupart des choses
qui vont hériter agaceries sait des
choses que six minutes plus tard soit
oublié pis il dit lille du tcd poser
question quelque chose dérange est ce
quelque chose qui va me déranger pendant
six minutes six jours ou si moi aussi at
il eu des choses qui vont déranger
pendant six mois aux six ans agit sur
sur l'homme et les trucs
six minutes après ou même six jours
après avoir passé par-dessus peut-être
fait un peu trop ample t exactement
sans parler d'alcool au début aussi puis
de dépendance comme ceux de crevin
souvent 10 h
après je prendre un verre et du repos
jorge semprun c'est juste ça il fait
beau je peux avoir une biatch a
peut-être que si j'en prenne je vais en
prendre six et peut-être que demain je
vois mal at elle fait juste de cette
bière je vais attendre dix minutes voire
encore
la prendre une demi heure ça passe quand
même chose quand essaie d'arrêter de
fumer sa part ce décret ring ça fait
juste passer une autre vie c'est juste
des crédits on passe d'un creux vignes à
d'autres avec si tu prends un peu de
recul face à ceux sur votre barre haute
et toute ta vie à partir d'un enfer à
d'autres au cellulaire alors dit un
billard cigarettes ont rejoint ou
on va faire retirer sa philippique entre
la première chose que tu apprends
d'administration de retraite de
méditation sict c'était silopi tu vis
avec des pensées c'est la fac de plus
toujours eu peur de faire c'est de
rester en contact
restait le seul avec toi même c'est pour
ça que c'est tellement puissant je pense
que ça change de veepee pour faire un
lien avec ce qu'on parle aux débutants
nouveau podcast puis je me dois de la
réponse à la question mais penses-tu
permettant la méditation peut est un des
outils pour combattre les problèmes de
santé mentale des prenez dépendance des
problèmes de de cette cellule
c'est certain ça devrait être
obligatoire de penser par
[Musique]
d'abord ça dans ton coffret otis est pas
une panacée rien de magique la dengue
celle ci était bipolaire ça va te
prendre des médicaments ça sera pas
méditation qui va te guérir sauf que la
méditation votre peut-être aidé à
prendre beaucoup moins de médicaments
d'avoir moins d'effets secondaires
on va t'aider à passer au travers des
plus facilement c'est la même chose ce
thème perdre quelqu'un ton entourage qui
décèdent la méditation
ça veut pas et que tu vas devenir un
robot plus tard open ça va ça va tarder
à passer au travers des plus facilement
par exemple
ben parce que tu vis un deuil à une
séparation une perte d'emploi la
méditation c'est la seule chose qui
va-t-on cris cse c'est plus diffus et en
étant la tendance à fuir on a tendance à
fuir justement on parle d'alcool on a
tendance à se dire au jour prendre une
bière je reprends une brosse
quelque chose qui m'arrive je vais
prendre un coup et la bcp est un
dépresseur fait que tb mr soit plus de
l'affronter une fois pour toute c'est
comme si tu arraches et d'un et charles
mathieu lagache la tumeur d'europe en
titre au pouget en écharde
je vais aller prendre une brasse pour
l'oublier parce que plus le nom de ma
tante
c'est venu de faire quelque chose
l'image
je pense que c'est toi qui la disaient
je m'en suis pas de caisse de mike
l'image de la mer avec les vagues de
dire totalité la mer puis les centres
les émotions si les petites vagues mais
finissent tout le temps par hrw ineo
tipi y aura tout le monde en parle
je pense que docteur arruda dit quelque
chose qui qui s'applique un petit peu à
ce concept là
pour éviter des conflits inutiles et dit
quand tu es fâché
prends pas de décision laisse
redescendre la colère avant la venue de
prendre action sur quelle est la
prochaine étape
puis le même principe pour pour pour
toutes les émotions en fait quand tu
réalises que toutes les émotions sont
des vagues d'agir au sommet de la vague
c'est possiblement pas la meilleure
façon d'agir
on s'identifie à nos émotions quand on
ressent de la colère on devient de la
colère combien on n'est pas au scandale
quand tu me dis tu te rends compte que
quelque chose en dessous de tout
quand la saint yves a ajouté li ciel
c'est que la colère a va arriver à
battre le peuple peut pas nier que la
colère parce que les aphtes peut être
légitimement colère dans vinh
sauf que ta colère peut l'observer
d'avoir un certain détachement comme ça
après impôts possession de l'émotion tu
n'es pas au bois devient peau tu deviens
pas l'émotion des conscient que
l'émotion et le mais tu t'identifies pas
l'émotion du prend du recul c'est sur la
méditation cette prise de recul
la calèche animations qui
les valorise ou qui veulent y est pour
beaucoup de gens et est perçu comme une
une émotion positive tu fais mon préféré
c'est une des mes lignes de films
préférés
la coupe qui s'engueulent seppi
justement le gorille decided tu vois la
colère qu'à une action positive qui
monotypie elle justement là pour ce
personnage-là colas comme un moteur
c'est comme quelque chose qui va faire
des jeunes en colère contre l'injustice
et encore à condition
ça me fait agir si le personnage il est
en désaccord avec ce mais mais mais
souvent justement se soucier
la colère va être revalorisée certaine
manière pis c'est valoriser parce qu'on
dit pour que ça sorte surtout pour les
hommes c'est valoriser une femme qui est
fort chez souvent de monza c'est une
crise de folles se comprend parce que
pâques avec contrôler ses émotions
c'est dommage mais c'est ça c'est mal vu
de se mettre en colère chez les hommes
c'est comme bien vu ben oui si c'est
viril 1 mais si c'était 6 5 c'est la
colère se sentirait pas coupable après
avoir exprimé sa colère c'est bien rare
qu'elles soient exprimés d'accolades
soit envoyé promener quelqu'un est une
donnée à petit en europe ou pas savaria
seuil est là la maison envoyé promener
quelqu'un vous mettez vous bernard mendy
s'est aussitôt que ça retombe
ben tu arrêter ben lui d'observer la
callas qui manque qui savoir cartes
dessins plutôt que d'être laissés aller
à la cale à cale à puce dans le
bouddhisme et au bouddhisme salir et des
racines asiatiques les asiatiques aux
autres la callas est vu comme une perte
de contrôle s'est pas vu comme quelqu'un
quelque chose qui est fort ce qui s'est
vu comme quelqu'un qui part belle à ce
contenu
jean-philippe on veut pas être chose du
tout assure toute la journée mais je
voulais aborder une dernière chose avec
toi en ce moment il ya beaucoup de à
cause du confinement les exports les
imports ont beaucoup réduit puis
beaucoup d'animaux en ce moment dans les
élevages qui vont être euthanasié parce
que ils seront jamais à mener à
l'abattoir
pour moi ce que ce sa demande c'est un
problème dans le système dans notre
façon de fonctionnement et on voit des
délais très des litres de lait qui sont
vidés dans des égouts parce que ils ont
peut pas les personnes les achètent
quelle est ta lecture de ces situations
là mais déjà que ces pots au corps et
que selon moi qu'on abatte des animaux
mais dès qu'on les hôtes en asie puis
quand désemparé que personne n'ait
concentre encore c'est terrible c'est
terrible mais il faut pas oublier que
c'est terrible drame apparaissent des
animaux ouais c'est vrai dans tous les
cas les gens c'est comme s'ils se
réveiller d'oeil à du gaspillage
alimentaire gaspillage alimentaire y en
a tout le temps eu l'épicerie que ce
pensent qu'ils font avec les élèves et
la viande qui est pas vendu le
championnat 33 % de la viande qui est en
épicerie est jeté mais ça veut dire que
33% des animaux qu'on a beau soit 150
milles
par 8 5 millions d'animaux par année au
canada
c'est des animaux une pierre qui sont
morts pour rien le tout donc on
s'insurge à cause qu'on va toujours
touche désir et en asie c'est en à la
même place mais ça nous met dans la face
aussi que pôle industrie josé un animal
c'est un bien commun aux retraités si
c'est déjà dommage quand même qu'on voit
mettons envoyer des cargaisons d'auto
d'automobiles dans un chantier pop
seront jamais utilisés qu'on jette ici
qu'on jette c'est parce que c'est du
gaspillage mais le cidc design vivante
pis si c'est comme si comme stella
pareil débat n'a pas besoin d'acheter un
cd meuble séparant une société ces
constats de certains animaux comme des
meubles comme des biens de consommation
jetable la seule valeur qui on sait le
pays
c'est ce que ça peut rapporter parce que
ça coûte à élever versus que le prix
quand le 20 mai c'est des animaux
certains animaux pour tout les animaux
rares centres étaient les chiens comme
on traite les prochains en arrêt ça
parce qu'aux nouvelles la photo je t'ai
manqué je parlais tout à l'heure tu vois
que cette insistance chien à cette
situation la police débarque
ben oui la truie qui est pas capable de
se tourner sur le côté qui pourrait se
lever debout si je mettais mon chien
langage il est trop petit pour lui
l'aspect à débarquer chez nous préparons
mais un bar c'est normal que ça arrive
comme ça mais mes paumes et pourquoi
quand pourquoi en fait ça arrive parce
que les gens continuent de manger
pourquoi pourquoi cesser les experts le
porte parole du québec fecq cell par la
plupart de la plupart du port qui fait
au québec s'en vont en chine
et puis en ce moment les exports sont
vraiment ralenti puis la demande est
beaucoup moins grande fait qu'on ait
pris avec des provisions de porcs à
définir qui le monde pour le lait par
exemple laissé jusqu'au québec on
confirme vraiment moins de lait par
l'intérieur de pandémie les gens
consomment moins et les restaurants sont
fermés
oui c'est une bonne chose que les gens
consomment moins diane mieux le vont
être arrêtées n'ont pas ou peu moins je
peux c'est êtes comme moi mais moi je
suis certain que dans une société qui va
être plus évoluée que la nôtre un moment
donné on évolue en tant que sociétés les
plus barbares nom de moins en moins
barbare mais les gens sont de plus en
plus éveillé où la souffrance animale
moi je certain que dans une société pas
si lointaine y en aura plus d'animaux le
qui vont en souffrir
on va regarder la ligne soit on répète
ce tintin qui mangeaient des animaux
absurde
je pense à disparaître concerne tant que
ça
notre société je suis certain que ce
sera possible
quand je regarde les jeunes de plus en
plus de jeunes qui sont venus chez moi
j'ai l'impression que ces métaux en ce
moment chez les je pense que c'est chez
les moins de 24 ans c'est vraiment un
pourcentage élevé de la population qui
végètent à rien puis j'ai l'impression
que quand ces gens-là vont être rendues
à des positions pas des positions de
pouvoir mais les positions décisionnel
j'ai l'impression que c'est là qu'ils
vont qu'on va vraiment voir le
souhaitent ce au péril
ce que ça va devenir la norme ouais
vegan végétalien ça va devenir la norme
exploite impériaux votre com ainsi que
la société s'en va parce qu'on part
d'une société qui est complètement
barbare des années 18 16 on pendait du
manque de pot l'antenne on parle plus du
monde sa place publique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ça fait pas
si longtemps que ça fait pas longtemps
nos en esclavage a fait pas si longtemps
que ça mais non c'est nos
arrière-grands-parents en bas d'une
génération y avait des choses qui
peuvent ceux qui peuvent se produire
surtout avec les médiums
tout le monde a accès à l'information
aujourd'hui nous fait manger bien que
j'ai bien confiance que peut-être pas
court terme à moyen terme la société
peuples à changer le monde
on espère on est ce pareil merci
beaucoup jean philippe c'était vraiment
super merci les amis à défaut d'une
petite retraite de méditation quand ça
va réouvrir vipassana google et sauve du
prêt nous vous avertissons gratuit j'y
pensais avant de parler qui je pense
encore plus maintenant de longues listes
d'attenté aux asturies
ça va me donner le temps elle a
recommencé à méditer xiam merci à aceh
quitté podcast pour 4 commence à vox à
fait disponible partout mon podcast le
géant philip shaw où on parle de
véganisme mes livres de recettes mais
plus préparé chez iga rachel berry est
ce que vous savez me trouvais web
l'accusé site web le cuisinier ça et
merci beaucoup merci les barreaux
babin